riley mao hit us with a news item
brother well
in a british wildlife park they have
removed five cursing parrots from public
okay when you say cursing parrots what
do you mean like parrots that they're
what
casting spells on on public i mean
that they have foul language oh vowels
have foul language
okay and any other information they're
giving you
um it just says that the birds shared
the ability to curse up a storm
something they engaged in quite often
okay so they're doing it and where is it
happening you said
in a british wildlife park yep
yep you know when i was young
riley you'd see a um
when i was young you'd see a mobile zoo
was popular
you know and that was a man had a nice
van or an extended van even sometime a
church van
and this man you know a man would have a
mobile zoo
and so you know somebody come through
town with a chimp and a uh
a small dolphin in an aquarium or
something in a big van you know and you
you know pay a dollar go see it or
somebody come through roll through with
two
chimps and a beagle and that was maybe
75
you go see to you know see them
and sometimes the beagle try to mate
with everybody beetle
beagle you know a deranged beagle will
[ __ ] anything
and that's probably that's practically
scripture man uh
but we had a fella come through town one
time and he had a couple of starlings i
believe
they were birds and um
and they curse you go give them a dollar
half dollar
and they call you the n word call you
the s word
you know call you a jew for a dollar
they call you a jew
and it was just a different time
uh
it was just a different time you know
when a man when a traveling zoo was more
you know they didn't have as much legal
issues
nowadays some you know you know friend
of mine got bit outside of a bj's pizza
by a damn uh
by a australian shepherd
and that's a lawsuit whereas when i was
young you'd pay maybe 50 cents for that
so we're living in different times man
um
and i'd be lying if i didn't tell you i
spent a couple dollars over there
because this fellow's little zoo broke
down by us and you get over here in a
starling we'd call you this or call you
that
you know sometime for you know dollar
fifty you could get you know
two n words and a jew out of the guy or
something you know out of the
thing or you know just you know you
could strike up a deal
and what kind of uh birds were they
riley does it say
um they are the
african african uh gray parrots
okay so that's almost i mean
let's be honest bro if it's african gray
that's almost a black
that's a you know that's an
african-american bird
you know i mean i know there's different
ways to say it and but still it's like
so if they're dropping them bombs is
that you know
i don't know if that really need if
that's
article worthy you know i get if you got
a white parrot letter or something out
there and he you know you got a toucan
and he's out there just humming in bombs
at people while they're trying to buy a
mouse or whatever
then that to me is risque but
you know this sounds just like nature
kind of figuring itself out
um you know in the 1600s 1700s they used
to use cows to find uh
like i don't want to say land mines or
but explosives and stuff
not 1700s but like 1800s 1900s and
they'd send them out there wandering out
there
you know until they
until they detonated it
so you know anything about that that
might have even been a far
asian trick uh riley have you had any
have you heard anything about that at
home any uh
on the home front any long to family
tales or anything like that
i've haven't no any of your family in
any of the wars
iwo jima famous war not that i know of
hmm
you seem like you might have a little
warrior in you
anybody ever told you that um no you
would be the first
that's cool bro thank you good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one